seis versos uno cita con hombres basado
en sus cuerpos
lleyton tendrá una cita con seis hombres
se elegirá a uno según su tipo de cuerpo
y personalidad hola soy leyton gb vivo
en minneapolis yo soy músico estudio
ciencias ambientales y soy modelo
[Música]
wang lin dos pies
están aprobados guau bien número uno
veamos sólo tienes marcas en tus uñas
pero porque hoy en día ocurrió marcas de
cuando he dejado caer herramientas sobre
mis pies y además me gusta la
carpintería así que así que te has
golpeado mucho
doloroso pero tienes buenos pies me
gusta gracias número dos
hola tus pies lucen muy bien pero veo
que tienes unas manchas allí que te paso
mucho más que poco me hicieron una
película y me pintaron las uñas yo traté
de ver el color por mi cuenta y quedaron
así
número 3 bien veo tus dedos sí de
acuerdo
desde aquí tus uñas se ven muy afiladas
desastre para cortarme las unidos y de
hecho hasta parece que podrías lastimar
a alguien con ella pero no sé cómo
cortarme las bien muy bien muy bien
igual me da miedo
creamos número 4 bien me gusta un pero
qué fiesta háblame de tus uñas
combinan con mis manos pero unas uñas
son más cortas que otras porque toco la
guitarra sé que es raro que no estén
parejas pero sí quiero que haya armonía
igual que con la ropa interior creo que
se ve mal no usar el mismo color bueno
entonces hoy no me veo bien que mal bus
número 5
eres grande
déjame adivinar no veo ninguna marca así
que dime a qué es lo que te dedicas yo
quiero convertirme en enfermero pero
ahora trabajo como asistente de
enfermería en un hospital increíble que
no hago mucho con mis pies por último me
encanta que todos muevan sus dedos
gracias son largos
miren eso muy ameno mejor de los de este
lado
bueno lo siento no quería que eso normal
pero yo me arregle por ti gracias yo te
lo agradezco mucho ronda 1 eliminación
layton debe eliminar a un hombre
eliminaré al número 3
sólo por sus uñas que pensé que aunque
sea alcanzaría saber me robe iniesta
opciones calzoncillos verbales morales
por dios a mi me diste tu oportunidad
está bien
grecia señor narval nunca juzgue a
alguien por sus pies me alegra que todos
ellos
puedan caminar bien ronda dos piernas
wow
se ve asustado sus pies están unidos
esto es raro quien tiene la mejor ropa
interior bien veamos uno observa este
lado de acuerdo descubrió que el número
dos el ganador
dígame qué tipo de cuerpo prefieren en
una pareja y además qué tan cómodos
están con sus cuerpos creo que prefiero
los cuerpos atléticos
porque me gusta realizar muchas
actividades me siento bien con mi cuerpo
me enfoco más en lo que puedo hacer que
en cómo luce muy bien bien dicho me
guste gusta cuidar de tu cuerpo que como
cuido de mi cuerpo me siento en un
comercial
como sano te gusta mi comida favorita es
tailandés número 2 me suelen traer los
cuerpos que son más curvilíneo para mí
lo más importante es la atracción pero
también me fijo mucho en la personalidad
tengo mucha confianza en mí mismo y no
me importa lo que los otros piensen
porque acepto mi cuerpo tal y como es
quisiera saber que te gusta más del
cuerpo de un chico
[Risas]
el cuerpo de un chico
puede que los ojos porque la gente dice
que son el espejo del alma yo me cuidaba
más en el pasado o incluso era mucho más
fuerte porque
practicaba la lucha libre de pequeño y
ahora solo canto y tato así que estoy
mucho más delgado y me he tenido que
ajustar a los cambios en el cuerpo no
tengo un tipo de cuerpo ideal pero creo
que es importante que te cuides a ti
mismo tanto tu apariencia como tu salud
es lo único que me importa que tengas
confianza en ti tampoco suelo ir al
gimnasio pero acompañó a mis amigos de
vez en cuando me siento bien con mi
cuerpo empecé a jugar baloncesto desde
que era muy pequeño y también he
ejercitado desde la secundaria para
fortalecer mis músculos así que si se no
me gustan me gustan las chicas más bajas
pero yo no creo que tenga un cuerpo
específico en mente me fijo más en el
rostro antes me dijiste que perdiste
algo de peso sí
bueno yo tuve un problema médico unos
doctores me recetaron unos medicamentos
que no me hacían bien y estuve en
terapia intensiva por un mes y medio y
yo dejé el tratamiento y mejoré pero
si eso fue qué bueno que estés bien
gracias sí me encantó estar viva
ronda 2 eliminación lleyton debe
eliminar a dos hombres pues todos
estuvieron geniales y no los quiero
eliminar creo que eliminar al número uno
hola desde un placer encantado qué
extraño es vernos así está igualada
tienes una figura muy hermosa granjero
también los es bien adiós
ahora
número 3 lo lamento los mejores pies o
la
verdad en cantar los números estoy
helada está bastante ronda 3 torso
bien aquí están
genial bien ahora podrían bailar un poco
para mí bien qué tal esto
lo haces muy bien
yo puedo hacer esto y saltar así
genial conocer a alguien por su baile
genial es eso pero qué quieren que haga
vale hábleme de sus tatuajes este es un
tatuaje de un girasol con hojas
no es muy profundo pero me encantan los
girasoles y cada vez que los veo me
siento bien así que me ayudan a recordar
lo bueno y me inspiran a ser feliz cada
día tienes muchos tatuajes es mi trabajo
no es genial me parece un arte
fascinante sí me encanta el de tu brazo
no solo como lo hacemos es tinta blanca
en lugar de negra este es mi primer
tatuaje lo hice durante uno de mis
viajes son recuerdos míos los paisajes
todos los que tengo hasta como un álbum
de recuerdos es increíble que hayas
hecho algo así número 3 sin tatuajes no
sin tatuajes lo siento estaría tras una
pasión y ccoo si no lo permiten pero
nunca se sabe piernas fuertes a mi buen
cuerpo estás en forma y eres fuerte eso
me gusta mucho y que podrían hacer por
mí si me sintiera mal lo que me gusta
hacer cuando estoy triste es buscar
actividades que me hagan sentir mejor
podrías ordenar tu habitación o
cualquier otra cosa que te anime sin
duda se atrasaría de escucharía y
trataría de hacerte sentir cómoda yo
intentaría darte mi apoyo y dejar los
consejos para después dejar fluir tus
emociones para luego abordarlo todos son
realmente asombrosos creo que eliminar
al número uno
sí porque no lo sé yo no tengo una razón
específica para
y creo que los demás fueron más
divertidos tal vez no te ofendas por
favor tú también eres gracias buen
cuerpo sino también debe ser muchas
gracias muy hermosa hoy gracias
[Risas]
bien creo que voy a eliminar al número
uno y
casi lo logras
hola hola cómo estás
soy lleyton y too late entonces lo
olvidé tranquila no baila me eliminaron
me encanta la historia que cuentan los
tatuajes en su cuerpo
[Música]
me alegra que haya salido de allí sí que
te parece si nos vamos juntos de picnic
y si estamos juntos por amazon a ambos
nos actuaremos por primera vez ahora que
ya se vieron que piensan el uno del otro
creo que eres hermosos bingo te lo
agradezco mucho si tú también es extraño
elegir a alguien sólo por su cuerpo pero
me das tu número sí gracias genial sabes
que no te llamaré muy bien con que no lo
harás gracias o eres famosa rayos tienes
76 mil seguidores
muy bien si sólo bromeo yo apenas llegó
a los 2 mil seguidores